when Liz truss has created an economic
crisis in Downing Street we're all gonna
have to pay for that to hire mortgages
higher bills for pretty much everything
and then she has the cheek not even to
acknowledge that but to accuse the rest
of the country of being part of this
anti-growth Coalition I mean quite
simply growth under the last Labor
government was considerably higher than
it has been under the last 12 years of
conservative government and I'd be very
confident in saying our plans for the
future are more realistic for stronger
growth than tax cuts for the already
built well-off if you're to try and get
higher growth as labor says it is do you
need to look at two policies that the
conservatives are famously a little bit
nervous about higher immigration and
looser planning regulation well the core
for us is the fact that this country has
the lowest rate of business investment
in the G7 so how do you drive that up
well you've got to get past the kind of
chaos economic instability you've had
under the last 12 years of conservative
government so I would say the main thing
is that a long-term policy framework a
modern industrial strategy institutions
that people have confidence in so they
know it's not going to change when
businesses I was asking about two
specific policies immigration planning
reform and I'm not clear what it is
specifically you're talking about in
your answer rather than you know
long-term strategies and it's about
business investment is the core of this
country's poor economic performance for
the last 12 years those two things that
they play some role but unless you're
attracting long-term investment to the
UK businesses having the confidence to
invest you're not going to see a change
to that and nothing I see in the
conservative
proposals for put forward so far address
the fact that they themselves to be
frank have been a cause of a lot of the
instability that has prevented that a
lot of businesses such as you know the
head of the CBI the biggest business
organization at Terry danker telling me
on Sunday the biggest thing is migration
people want to see and more immigrants
coming to the UK to try and help fill
some of those all-important jobs would
labor like to see higher immigration
well look I accept the point if you talk
to most businesses they will identify
labor and skill shortages as a major
barrier to growth we've got to accept
immigration is high at the minute it's
different to how it was under freedom of
movement but we're members of the EU but
it is high so we would like to see a
closer relationship between immigration
numbers the shortage occupation list and
the skills investment that goes on in
the UK so if you are putting an
occupation on the shortage occupations
list you're also triggering a response
from government in terms of the
investment in skills investment in this
country so people can have confidence
there's a long-term plan that isn't just
based on immigration I recognize it's a
big issue for businesses but they've got
to accept that the public have concerns
about that too so do you say that
immigration is hard you think it's too
high immigration has to reflect the
needs of the economy and the fact that
let's be frank we're an aging population
and we've got to bring people into this
country I don't think getting back to
where you know the conservative
governments of the past have been about
putting arbitrary Targets on it is in
any way helpful for the simple fact they
never got anywhere near those targets so
what's the point in having them I don't
think that's a helpful way to do it
you're going to acknowledge public
concerns as well as acknowledge business
concerns that this is a significant
problem for them okay
now just you know we're back in London
now we're here in Westminster I've been
to both labor and the conservative
conference I have to say there was a
pretty clear difference in atmosphere of
both
how does it feel
for as a labor politician to be looking
at the conferences and the inviting is
not at labor for once but at the
conservatives well look I'm also pleased
to see labor doing well I want us to be
leading in the opinion polls but look
we've had to earn that we've had to
recognize the defeat in 2019 have a
leader in Kia storm who's moved the
party on and listened frankly to where
people weren't willing to support labor
in the past so look we we're doing what
we can I'm going to continue doing what
we can to continue to build and earn
that trust it is true I mean you look at
conservative conference it looks chaotic
it looks like there's no kind of
internal discipline or consistent
approach to any issue but look that is
that is set from the top it comes from
this trust it comes from quasi quatang
and I think to be honest until they are
willing to acknowledge the scale of the
economic crisis they created with that
mini budget and what it means for every
household every family it is the whole
economic crisis so did they come on I
mean look at inflation rates globally
look at the war in Ukraine look at you
know what's happening those are factors
look at government borrowing I mean what
they created with that mini Budget on
Friday Friday was an increase in
government borrowing costs so
historically unprecedented it took a
substantial intervention from the bank
of England to save the defined benefit
pension industry in the UK these are not
small things I mean look at where if you
want to get a new mortgage if you
remortgaging or buying a property right
now look at the best fixed term rate you
will get it's around six percent it's a
real significant changes that come not
just from Individual policy decisions
that were made but from people looking
at this government and saying this is a
government that we can't trust we can't
trust them to have faith and respect for
the institutions that we base our
economic policy making on in this
country and once you've lost that
confidence it's very very hard to get
back and neither litros or quasi quarter
and in my view will ever get that
confidence back um you say that neither
Liz trust or quasi quantity in your view
will get the economic confidence back
conservative MPS famously ruthless in
getting rid of leaders do you think
you'll be facing Liz trust at the next
election well look it's clearly been a
disastrous start but she's responsible
for that she will have to own that I
would genuinely say no you expect me to
want a general election because I'm in
opposition and I'd like to replace the
government political instability does
have a corresponding effect on economic
instability and if the conservative
party thinks it can change its leader
again so soon without a corresponding
impact of that on people's lives on
their incomes again on their mortgages
well they've got to acknowledge they
would have that so the genuine soundest
safest thing for this country would be a
general election and a chance to replace
the conservative party in government
entirely are you on an election fitting
now then yes and we've got to be but
look we've had elections at short notice
in the past so I think everyone from
2019 onwards has always had that but
we're going to continue doing what we've
done since that defeat which is
acknowledge where we went wrong win back
people's trust have clearly costed
policies have a commitment to a kind of
fiscal responsibility which is
completely lacking from this government
and I feel very confident very happy
with the labor party on its current
direction under Kia Stormer and we'll
continue to do the work we've got to do